hi in this module i'm going to show you
how you can use the machinery of linear
predictors that we've developed so far
to get some non-linear predictors
so we're going to first focus on
regression and then later talk about
classification
so remembering regression we're given
some training data we have a learning
algorithm that produces a predictor
and the first key question or design
decision is which predictors is the
learning algorithm allowed to choose
from that's the question of the
hypothesis class
so for
linear predictors remember that the
hypothesis class is defined to be the
set of all predictors f x equals
some weight vector dot some feature
vector phi of x
and we allow the wave vector to range
freely over all d dimensional real
vectors okay so if we take phi of x
equals one comma x like we did before
then
we can get some lines
so if we set the weight vector to be one
comma zero point five seven then we get
this line with an intercept at 1 and a
slope of 0.57
and here's a purple one with the
intercept
of 2 and a slope of 0.2
so all is good
but what happens if we get data that
looks like this if you try to fit a line
through it you won't be very happy with
this
you really want to fit some sort of
non-linear predictor something that can
curve around to fit the data
so your first reaction might be to reach
for something like neural networks or
decision trees something that's more
complex but let's see how far we can get
with just using linear predictors
so the key thing
is that
the feature vector
can be arbitrary
so let's take the feature vector to be
one comma x as before but let's just add
on an x squared term
okay just for fun and so for example if
we feed x equals three then we get the
future vector one comma
nine
um let's define some weights two comma
one comma zero point two
add and let's plot what that function
looks like
and we get a nice curve
so that's a nonlinear predictor so it
has a intercept of 2 a slope
of one at the origin and a curvature of
negative zero point two
here's another one four comma
minus one comma zero point one
there's an intercept of four a slope of
minus 1 and a curvature of 0.1
and here's another one 1 1 0. so what
does this one look like this one just
looks like a line because we've used a
zero weight on this x squared term so it
just reduces to a linear predictor
in general we can define a family of all
quadratic predictors
that looks like this by ranging the wave
vector freely over all
three dimensional vectors
so here is our first example of getting
a non-linear predictor in particular
quadratic predictors just by changing
feet
the one small note here is that in one
dimension
x squared is just a single feature
but if x were d dimensional to begin
with then to get the range full range of
quadratic predictors we would need d
squared features one for every x i xj
pair
so that would be a lot
so that's one slight disadvantage of
using the machinery of linear predictors
to get nonlinear predictors
let's move on
so quadratic predictors are great but
they can only kind of vary smoothly
what happens if you want
a function that looks like this
so here's an example of a piecewise
constant predictor
and we can get this predictor also by
just reimagining what a feature vector
is so here
is uh i'm going to define phi of x
equals
and the first i'm going to carve up the
input space into a bunch of regions
and define a feature to be
whether x lies in that region or not
the first feature is tests whether x is
between 0 and 1
and the indicator function will return 1
if that's true and 0 otherwise
um the second one is going to test
between 1 and 2
and so on
so here's an example if you punch in 0
2.3
that is 0 on all the feature slash
regions except for
this one
okay so if i set the weight vector
corresponding to one two four four three
then i get this function
and notice that each weight
is just identifying the function value
of that region so between 0 and 1 the
feature
vector is
sorry the function is at 1 and then it's
2 and then it's 4 and then it's 3.
okay so here's another one
it's 4 and then 3 3 to
1.5
and again in general the set of
predictors is
w dot v of x where w can range
so this is a general technique uh
piecewise constant functions which can
give you expressive nonlinear predictors
by partitioning the input space
again a caveat is that
everything looks nice in one dimension
but if d x were d dimensions and each
dimension were carved up into b regions
then you have b to the d different
features which is an exponential number
of features which is a kind of a no go
so
you can kind of get the idea now but
let's just do another example suppose
you're trying to
predict a function with some periodic
structure like you're trying to predict
uh traffic patterns or sales of across a
year
so imagine that you want to get a
function that looks like
this okay
so let's see if we can hack together a
feature vector that does that so v of x
equals one x
and x squared so put in the quadratic
and now let's add a cosine three
it's kind of arbitrary
um
so here's an example if you punch 2 into
x then you get this feature vector
um if you define the weights in a
certain way
then you get that red
curve you can take define the weights
this way and then you get the purple
curve and then so on
so here the kind of a key idea is that
you can really go wild you can throw in
any sort of features you want and get
all sorts of wacky looking predictors
all using the machinery of linear
predictor
so you might say wait a minute wait a
minute
how are we able to
do this get all this expressive
non-linear capabilities when we haven't
really changed the learning algorithm or
it's it's still supposed to be a linear
predictor right
um
well
that's because the word linear is a
little bit ambiguous here
so remember the prediction is w dot p of
x so that's the score
and the question is what
linear in what
so is the score linear in w
yes because the score is just some
constant times w
is it linear in phi of x
yes because
uh it's something times v of x
how about is it linear in x
well the answer is no because phi of x
can be arbitrary so it doesn't have to
be linear x
and the key idea behind non-linearity is
that there's two ways of viewing it from
the point of view of gaining expressive
non-linear predictors this is great
because you can define phi of x to be
something and get arbitrary non-linear
functions out
but from the point of view of having to
learn such a
model
it's actually great because the score is
a linear function of w
and when you're learning you take the
gradient with respect to w so it's just
a kind of score is just a linear
function so
uh life is great in fact the learning
algorithm doesn't even care what fee is
it only looks at the data through the
lens of p of x it doesn't know whether
you gave it x and then applied fee or
you just gave it p of x directly
okay so now let's turn from regression
to classification the store is story is
pretty much the same you can define
arbitrary features and get nonlinear
classifiers
but just to kind of review
remember in linear classification you
define in two dimensions you define the
feature vector to be x1 comma x2
and if you define
the predictor
as now a sign here
and the sign
allows you to partition define the
decision boundary which separates the
region of the space which is labeled
plus from the region of space which is
labeled minus
okay so now what is non-linear mean well
if you look at f of x because of the
sine functions it's already non-linear
so it doesn't really make sense so
instead non-linearity for a
classification means whether the
decision boundary is linear or not in
particular here is it a line
and if we define the feature vector as
x1 x2 then we just get a line
so so now let's try to do something a
little bit more interesting so let's see
if we can define a quadratic classifier
suppose we wanted to define a classifier
that looks like this so it's a circle
the decision boundary is a circle where
inside the circle we want to label as
plus and outside we want to label as
minus
okay so how are we going to do that
well let's start with a feature vector
equals uh x1 x2 as we had before and now
we're just going to tack on a quadratic
term so x1 squared plus x2 squared
okay
and now if you define the corresponding
weight vector to be 2 2 minus 1 then i
claim that this gives you exactly this
decision boundary
which is a circle
so there's some algebra that you can do
which i'm going to uh
skip over but what you can do is you can
rewrite this expression
as follows
so f of x the same f of x is equal to 1
if
this quadratic form is less than or
equal so what is this you might remember
from
kind of algebra uh trigonometry days
that this is the squared distance of a
point to the point one one
okay so in particular if i
constrain the squared distance to be
less than or equal to 2 then this
is the region of points
with within radius square root of 2 of a
circle centered at 1 1 which is exactly
what this is
and everything else is classified as -1
so the zoom boundary
we got successfully to be a circle
okay so
this is let me try to take one more step
to try to reconcile this tension between
linear
in phi of x and nonlinear and x okay so
what we're going to do here is
remember the input space
x
this decision boundary is a circle
and in feature space
you can see that the decision boundary
is a line
so here is a cool
animation that i found on youtube which
i think
really nicely illustrates this
so this is done in context of svm but
the idea is the same so here we have
points in inside the circle and outside
the circle in the ambient
x space they're not separable what we're
going to do is we're going to apply the
feature map and the feature map remember
adds this third dimension
x1 squared plus x2 squared and now we're
in feature space which is 3d
and in 3d we can actually slice a linear
predictor that separates the green of
the red and the blue points
and that separation
induces a circle in the
original 2t 2tsp
okay to summarize
so
linear is ambiguous
so we have a predictor
in a case of regression which is w dot v
of x
it's linear in w and phi of x but it's
non-linear in x
and this is what allows us to get
nonlinear predictors using the machinery
of linear predictor
we solve for regression nonlinearity
talks about the predictor directly and
classification we talk about the
decision boundary
we also saw many types of nonlinear
features quadratic features piecewise
constant periodic features and again you
can kind of make up your own features
for the application you have in mind
so next time someone on the street asks
you about linear predictors you first
have to clarify linear and what
okay that's the end
you